heinsberg stephan pusch professor martin
hendrick stieg von universität bonn wo
er sagte hartmann und professor stehen
im anschluss auch noch für fragen zur
verfügung zuerst hat das board
ministerpräsident laschet ja meine damen
und herren ich habe in den letzten
wochen immer wieder betont dass wir
einen dreiklang von zielen braun erster
die verlangsamung der ausbreitung des
virus darauf waren alle anstrengungen
gerichtet zweitens der ausbau unseres
gesundheitssystems binnen weniger wochen
die intensiv plätze die geräte alles so
bereitzustellen dass am tag iks genügend
kapazitäten in nordrhein-westfalen
verhandeln sind und dass dritte die
abfederung der folgen der pandemie für
unser land für unsere wirtschaft und für
jeden einzelnen und damit die
vorbereitung auf die zeit nach der krise
und diese überlegungen für die zeit nach
der krise mussten immer schon parallel
erfolgen
man kann nicht erst kurzfristig
entscheiden jetzt ändern wir wieder die
restriktionen sondern man braucht eine
begründung eine fundierte begründung und
deshalb haben wir diese
wissenschaftliche studie in auftrag
gegeben um am beispiel des kreises
heinsberg einmal zu ermitteln welche
dunkelziffer gibt es wir sind
übertragungswege gewesen wie kann man an
diesem muster kreis den es nirgendwo in
europa so konzentriert gibt wie im kreis
heinsberg wie kann man von dort aus zur
erkenntnissen kommen die dann wieder für
die politik von bedeutung sind und zwar
von anfang an bewusst dass die
pauschalen einschränkungen der lockdown
das herunterfahren des gesamten
öffentlichen sozialen wirtschaftlichen
lebens die einschränkung von
grundrechten immer eine begründung
bedarf und dass man immer abwägen muss
ob es ein
milderes mittel gibt um am ende das
gleiche ziel zu erreichen und wir können
mit aller vorsicht heute sagen die
zahlen zu den bestätigten kobe 19 fällen
in nordrhein westfalen zeigen ein
abflachen der zuvor deutlich
ansteigenden kurve die verdopplung
zahlen der infektionen verändern sich
von tag zu tag im kreis heinsberg sogar
zwei wochen vor der
nordrhein-westfälischen und der
deutschen entwicklung und im rest des
landes derzeit schneller als im
bundesdeutschen schnitt und deshalb
müssen wir lösungen finden die freiheit
und gesundheit der menschen besser als
bisher miteinander in einklang bringen
wir haben einen expertenrat berufen dem
auch herr professor streek angehört aber
auch ethiker soziologen philosophen
wirtschaftsexperten die uns deutlich
gemacht haben
auch jetzt erleben wir schäden der
deutsche ethikrat hat davon gesprochen
die schäden durch den lockdown auch die
muss man in rechnung stellen und dann
immer wieder zu einer abwägung kommen
und deshalb bin ich froh dass das
forschungsprojekt cupid 19 pace cluster
study heute einen zwischenbericht
vorlegen kann professor strick und sein
team haben in den letzten zehn tagen mit
hochdruck tag und nacht zum teil daten
erhoben und erste auswertungen
vorgenommen
ich freue mich dass sie herr professor
strikt heute diese zwischenergebnisse
vorstellen
ich freue mich aber auch dass zum team
professor gunther hartmann vom institut
für klinische chemie und klinische
pharmakologie an der universität bonn am
universitätsklinikum bonn mit dabei ist
er ist auch sprecher des
exzellenzclusters der universität bonn
was zu den wenigen exzellenzclustern
überhaupt in deutsch
gehört und deshalb über die forschung
von heimischen professor streik auch die
erweiterung auf andere
wissenschaftsbereiche mit unterstreicht
und macht den ex professor macht den ex
neues vom institut für hygiene und
öffentliche gesundheit und er ist
ebenfalls an der universität bonn so
dass auch an der universität
unterschiedliche medizinische
fachrichtungen aus unterschiedlichen
gesichtspunkten diese studie begleitet
und diese ergebnisse mit vortragen
auch die stehen ihnen nachher zum
ergebnis zur verfügung die erkenntnisse
sollen unsere politischen entscheidungen
in der nächsten woche wenn die
ministerpräsidentin mit der
bundeskanzlerin zusammen kommen
unterstützen
aber es ist ein zwischenergebnis und das
müssen wir auch hier klar sagen es wird
einen endbericht geben die kriterien die
man ausgewählt hat sind nach den
kriterien der
weltgesundheitsorganisation getroffen
worden
wie viele haushalte wie viele personen
muss man nach welchen kriterien befragen
es sind doppelt so viele haushalte
bereits jetzt ausgewertet als von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation als
richtlinie genannt werden aber am ende
der studie werden es vier mal so viele
haushalte seien wie die
weltgesundheitsorganisation vorschreibt
nur das ermutigt uns heute diesen dieses
zwischenergebnis vorzulegen und wir sind
sehr gespannt auf das was sie uns ein
professor strikt jetzt zu ihren studien
vortragen er ist würde ich doch ganz
kurz das wort an herrn landrat stephan
pusch
ich brauch kein wasser jaja
ministerpräsident sehr geehrte herren
professoren meine damen und herren heute
ist hier der tag wo ich mal ganz
ausdrücklich für den kreis heinsberg für
die bevölkerung chrysler stanke sagen
möchte
während wir hier jetzt die
pressekonferenz abhalten werden gerade
in gangelt und das findet jetzt seit
über zehn tagen gab zwei wochen statt
mit hochdruck die letzten proben
genommen
die bevölkerung hat in einer
unwahrscheinlichen art und weise mit
über 80 prozent beteiligung zum teil von
denen die angeschrieben wurden diese
studie begleitet ich glaube das ist auch
einzigartig dass man bei einer studie so
eine beteiligung hat wir haben mit den
mit der uni bonn mit herrn professor
strikt schon nach unserer
pressekonferenz hier vor gut zwei wochen
an dem samstag schon gesessen und quasi
über das wochenende die organisation
jemand für sowas brauch aus dem boden
gestampft und glaubt da hat es ein
richtig gutes thema gegeben zwischen
mitarbeitern meiner verwaltung zwischen
den wissenschaftlern
ich glaube dass man heute überhaupt
schon ergebnisse hat ist eigentlich
sensationell wenn man wenn man überlegt
wie so eine studie quasi dann aus dem
boden gestampft worden ist aber wir alle
wissen zeit ist bei diesen ganzen dingen
ein sehr kritischer faktor denn auch das
muss man sagen ich bin heute hier auch
um etwas mut zu machen haben auf der
einen seite die mit sicherheit die
situation dass unsere wirtschaft leidet
das unternehmen leiden das wird mir
jeden tag gespiegelt wir haben bestimmte
branchen und wie haben die preislich
etwas länger den shutdown die besonders
leiden gastronomie reisebüros kleiner
unternehmen einzelhandel also alles das
gibt uns die verpflichtung zu überlegen
und das wird auch passieren wie kommen
wir da aus der situation am besten
wieder raus man sieht aber auch dass der
kreis heißt mut machen kann denn wir
sind aktuell in einer situation wo die
fallzahlen nicht nur stagnieren die
zuwachsraten sondern wo wäre denn wir
die fallzahlen vergleichen die aktuell
infizierten sehen dass wir sogar eine
fallende kurse haben
ich möchte mit aller vorsicht sagen dass
der kreis heinsberg über den berg ist
das ist immer schwierig in solchen
situationen aber wir haben zumindest
zahlen die wirklich mut machen und man
sieht dann auch dass maßnahmen
und ich erwarte auch dass das bezogen
auf das land auch in den nächsten tagen
die kurven flachen ab der fall sein wird
das heißt die maßnahmen wirken wie
eindämmungspolitik war richtig und das
land hat auch in den letzten tagen sehr
sehr viele weise entscheidungen
getroffen die dabei helfen werden der
ministerpräsident sprach an die
ausweitung der intensivbetten
kapazitäten die uns darauf vorbereiten
situationen gewachsen zu sein wo wir
dann auch wieder das öffentliche leben
mit aller vorsicht wahrscheinlich wieder
angehen werden ich möchte mich aber dann
wirklich mal bei den wissenschaftlern
bei den menschen im kreis bedanken
ich denke so was kann mut machen wir
müssen nach vorne gucken ich glaube es
bleibt alles gar nichts anderes über wir
haben natürlich eine situation und die
wird uns weiterhin sorgen machen und die
wird uns begleiten und da wird es
wahrscheinlich auch keine patentlösung
geben das sind die alten und pflegeheime
die sowohl radeln einrichtungen da bei
aller aller diskussionen die wir führen
wissen wir dass das nach wie vor nur mit
der strengen maßnahmen möglich sein wird
da erhöhte todeszahlen zu vergleichen
und wenn ich ohne herrn professor
vorzugreifen sehe wie viele personen
unerkannt in der dunklen zimmer sind
dann muss ich sagen der kreis heinsberg
ist an einer riesengroßen katastrophe
vorbeigeschlittert
wir haben glück im unglück gehabt wir
haben zu einem sehr frühen zeitpunkt
gott sei dank festgestellt dass die
infektionszahlen haben und wir waren
dadurch in der lage sehr früh massnahmen
aufzusetzen ich denke wenn das nicht
passiert wäre wenn nur ein oder zwei
wochen später diese situation bekannt
gewordenes bekannt geworden wäre und
unsere maßnahmen erst landen eingetreten
werden und dann erst hätten ergriffen
werden können dann hätten wir viel viel
schlimmere situation im kreis heinsberg
erlebt so ist die situation moment
entspannt die intensiv kapazitäten der
krankenhäuser auch ein wichtiger faktor
sind nicht überlastet wir haben nur 60
70 prozent belegung bei den
intensivbetten das scheint auch in
deutschland ein großer pluspunkt zu sein
dass wir wirklich auch intensiv
bettenkapazitäten haben denn ich glaube
das ist die grundvoraussetzung dafür
neben den bekannten faktoren
beatmungsgerät und schutzkleidung die
denke ich mal mit die maßgabe dafür sein
müssen wie man in den nächsten wochen in
deutschland damit umgehen kann ich
wünsche dem ministerpräsident wünschte
auch der kanzlerin nächste woche eine
gute hand bei ihren entscheidungen viel
fortüne und wir alle wissen es ist
bleibt irgendwo
eine prognose entscheidung die man
treffen kann aber die politik auch
treffen muss bei der politik mit
wissenschaft zusammenarbeiten muss ich
glaube im kleinen ist das im kreis
heinsberg gelungen ich denke im großen
mit dass der politik auch gelingen viel
glück dabei danke ja herzlichen dank
herr landrat pusch nun durch das wort an
herrn professor hendrik streik geben
vielen dank vielen dank herr
ministerpräsident laschet landrat pusch
ich möchte als allererstes sagen dass
ich hier nicht alleine stehe sondern
dass das ein große teamarbeit war ganz
allen voran herrn günter hartmann der
einfach auch die wissenschaftliche
exzellenz dabei unterstreicht und mit
seinem ganzen team dahinter stand von
der studienzentrale bis zur klinischen
chemie wirklich viele mitgearbeitet
haben professor martin exner hat er ja
sehr bekanntes als hygieniker der auch
mit denen wir gestern abend bis in den
späten die nacht zusammen saßen um die
daten zu interpretieren und einzuordnen
und das geht eben nur gemeinsam
interdisziplinär als ein team um
ergebnisse zu finden nun dienstag haben
wir bereits die methodik einmal noch mal
ausführlicher vorgestellt
und hier nur noch mal ganz kurz die
wichtigsten parameter der studie die wie
sie alle wissen ist die gemeinde gangelt
einer der am stärksten von kogit 19
betroffenen regionen in deutschland und
wir haben uns an ein velo protokoll was
öffentlich zugänglich ist orientiert was
bei solchen hochprävalenzregionen
vorschlägt dass zwischen 100 bis 300
haushalte eingeladen werden 100 reicht
bei einer hoch prävalenz
hochprävalenzregionen wir haben mit
einem serienbrief wir haben eine
repräsentative stichprobe gesucht von
der biometrie unter der leitung von
herrn professor schmid und haben 600
haushalte angeschrieben in insgesamt
kamen haben über 1000 einwohner an der
studie teilgenommen und über 400 haut
was über 400 haushalten entspricht
was hier gemacht haben nur kurz wir
haben fragebogen erhoben einen
rachenabstrich genommen um mit der pcr
methode nachzuweisen aber derzeit eine
infektion vorliegt und wir haben blut
abgenommen um zu sehen mit einem mittels
eines antikörpertest ob eine infektion
stattgefunden hat in dieser auswertung
welche ganz explizit sagen dass wir die
zwischenergebnisse vorstellen
zwischenergebnisse aus 500 in über 500
individuell 509 individuen und ungefähr
die hälfte der haushalte also die daten
können sich ein wenig verschieben dabei
wie das bei der statistik ist aber auch
die 500 500 personen ist schon eine
repräsentative stichprobe des weiteren
werden noch weitere themenbereiche
analysiert zum einen die
karnevalssitzungen um zu verstehen wie
wieder das ausbruchsgeschehen gewesen
ist zum anderen unter der leitung von
professor exner und ricarda schmidt
hausen auch umwelt und umweltproben um
zu verstehen wo sich das virus genau
befindet an so ein beispiel kann man
auch gut sagen dass das nur in einer
zusammenarbeit zwischen virologie und
hygiene geht wie die proben dort
gesammelt werden ist wirklich sehr
kompliziert und wird versuchen dann aber
bei uns im labor so ein virus dann auch
an zu züchten wieder was aus der umwelt
gefunden wurde
das ziel der studie sind stand der
durchgemachten und noch stattfindenden
saas sowie zwei infektionen in der
gemeinde gangelt zu verstehen in dieser
repräsentativen stichprobe wir
ist es ja ein gebiet wo sehr viel
getestet wurde das muss man sich auch
noch vergegenwärtigen nämlich wenn in
einem hohen testgebiet also wo sehr
viele personen einfach schon mal ein
abstrich zentrum gekommen sind wird
meistens erst mal eine die die
dunkelziffer überschätzt während den
niedrig testgebieten wie im rest von
deutschland die dunkelziffer meistens
unterschätzt wird
es wurde eine bestehende immunität
umgangen der gemeinde gangelt von circa
14 prozent nachgewiesen
danach immunglobulin das bedeutet dass
14 eine infektion durchgemacht haben
etwa zwei prozent der person hatten ein
mittels pcr ein nachweis von saas sowie
zwei was bedeutet dass sie derzeit eine
saas sowie zwei eine unerkannte saas
sowie zwei infektionen haben
ich muss dazu sagen dass dies insgesamt
haben wir also eine infektionsrate dort
von 15 prozent in der gemeinde gangelt
in der stichprobe nachgewiesen
dies ist eher konservativ gerechnet muss
ich dazu sagen aber wir fanden ist es
eher gute konservativ zu rechnen
die haben auch noch andere methoden
angewandt wo wir auch einen etwas
höheren wert von der infektionsrate in
der gemeinde kommen
damit ergibt sich eine letalität bezogen
auf die gesamtzahl der infizierten in
der gemeinde gangelt ein mit den
vorläufigen daten die wir jetzt hier
haben von 0,37 die in deutschland
derzeit von der
johns-hopkins-universität berechnete
letalität also die gemeldete zahl der
sterbezahlen und gemeldete zahl der
infizierten beträgt derzeit rund 1,98
und liegt damit um das fünffache höher
die mortalität also wie viele menschen
aus der bevölkerung an
dem virus versterben die gesamt der
gesamt population beträgt derzeit 0,06
prozent nun um das einzuordnen
die johns hopkins einmal berechnet die
fünffach höhere letalität immer im
vergleich zwischen von wie viele
wirklich infiziert gewesen sind im
vergleich zu denen die verstorbenen sind
dadurch wir haben wir hier auch milder
symptomatischer personen eingeschlossen
die gar nicht gemerkt haben zum beispiel
dass sie eine infektion hatten in
gangelt können wir da von allen der
gemeinde gangelt und kreis heinsberg
können wir davon ausgehen dass die 15
prozent der bevölkerung derzeit eine
immunität gegen saas sowie zwei
ausgebildet haben das ist wichtig denn
das bedeutet auch dass 15 prozent der
bevölkerung in der gemeinde gangelt sich
nicht mehr mit saas sowie 2 derzeit
infizieren können
und dieser 15 prozentige anteil der
bevölkerung bedeutet auch eine gewisse
verlangsamung in der ausbreitung weil
das natürlich diese 15 prozent nicht
mehr infiziert werden können in unserer
schluss fall gemeinsam schlussfolgern
gehen denken meinen wir dass die s
einheiten von studenten hygienemaßnahmen
das durch durch das einhalten zu
erwarten ist dass die virus
konzentration generell reduziert werden
kann und das den schweregrad der
erkrankung und ausbreitung
entgegengewirkt wird das gleichzeitig
mit dem zur gleichzeitigen ausbildung
der immunität dass diese günstigen
voraussetzungen wie zum beispiel
außergewöhnlichen ausbruchs ereignissen
wie in ischgl oder karnevalssitzungen
bergamo spielen die sind im moment nicht
mehr gegeben
also dass durch das einhalten von
hygienemaßnahmen auch eine günstige
effekt auf die gesamtmortalität geben
wird und daher unterstützten und
empfehlen wir ausdrücklich die
vorgeschlagenen
vier phasen strategie der deutschen
gesellschaft für krankenhaushygiene dgkh
und das kurze eck kann er noch ich
spiele dann noch mal näher erläutern
vorzustellen die phase 1 ist das ist
eine gesellschaftliche tarantini sierung
mit dem ziel die eindämmung und
verlangsamung der pandemie und
vermeidung eine überlastung der
kritischen versorgungsstrukturen
insbesondere gesundheits
versorgungssysteme in dieser phase
befinden wir uns gerade und damit hat
die politik richtig reagiert und
unkontrollierte ausbrüche zu verhindern
dadurch dass die menschen so aktiv und
diszipliniert aber jetzt im weiten
teilen mitmachen ist uns jetzt möglich
in die eine phase 2 einzutreten
die nämlich von der dgkh besagt dass
eine beginn der rücknahme der
quantifizierung bei gleichzeitiger
sicherung der hygienischen
rahmenbedingungen und verhaltensweisen
in anderen worten wir haben gelernt wie
wir uns hygienisch richtig verhalten und
damit stark der des ausbruchs geld
geschehen entgegengewirkt in der phase 3
besagt dass die aufhebung der quarantäne
sierung phase 3 besagt die aufhebung der
charakterisierung unter beibehaltung
jenische rahmenbedingungen und die phase
4 ist dass der status quo ante des
zustand des öffentlichen lebens wie vor
der prophet 19
[Musik]
dabei ist in unseren augen auch wichtig
eine weitere kennziffer in den
vordergrund zu rücken an rücken und
stärker im auge zu behalten
das ist die anzahl der krankenhausbetten
der beatmung
der gepard muss geräte und der intensiv
plätze und daher ist der ausbau eines
zentralregisters die von ihren sparen
angestoßen durchaus richtig und wichtig
in dieser pandemie
zum schluss möchte ich noch sagen wir
müssen lernen mit saas zwei zu leben und
die gefahren richtig einzuordnen
das ist aufgabe der wissenschaftler wir
sind hier auch im engen austausch mit
dem robert-koch-institut und schauen wie
unsere studie zusammen mit dem
robert-koch-institut weitergetragen
werden kann
diese erste wissenschaftliche studie die
soeben nur ein soll einen beitrag dazu
leisten und wir werden die arbeit in den
nächsten wochen weiter intensivieren
fortsetzen und auch ein endergebnis am
ende präsentieren um so weit es geht
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse zu
erlangen und damit der politik noch eine
bessere grundlage zu geben für ihre
entscheidung
denn eins ist uns drei als
wissenschaftler auch wichtig wir können
einen beitrag leisten die iren wie
beispielsweise jetzt sowie zwei besser
zu verstehen und die politik dabei zu
unterstützen
aber die entscheidung sollte kann kann
und die kann soll nur die politik
treffen da sie auch viele andere aspekte
abseits der wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse zu berücksichtigen hat zum
schluss möchte mich noch bei den
bürgerinnen im kreis heinsberg ein
vorrang herrn landrat pusch und der
gemeinde gangelt bedanken ich möchte
mich beim gesundheitsamt bei heidrun
schüßler bedanken die uns sehr
unterstützt hat und vor allem aber auch
dem gesamten team von der studie
dem team des universitätsklinikum
bedanken die in den letzten tagen
maximalen einsatz gezeigt haben
herzlichen dank großer strebt jetzt
beginnen wir mit den fragen uns eine
menge schon erreicht nun wirklich einmal
professor hartmann peter exner mit nach
vorne binden das seien die fragen
zunächst an die wissenschaftler
gerichtet werden und wir kriegen einen
motor an ihren ruf der extra die
erfahrung zeigt dass ich hier übergeben
wir stehen sonst im bild das ist aber
wir wir kriegen sind herzlich
eingefangen und fragen ihrem mann fritz
mayer von der deutschen presse agentur
herdorf tricks sie haben eben gesagt man
kann jetzt in die phase 2 eintreten
beginnende rücknahme der
charakterisierung bei gleichzeitiger
sicherung wir gehen diese
rahmenbedingungen verhaltensweisen
können sie konkret sagen was das jetzt
bedeutet aufgrund dieser ersten
zwischenergebnisse samstag die politik
muss bestimmen aber was könnten die
wissenschaftler denn jetzt sagen wie
weit könnte man die auflagen lockern
nach ostern darf würde ich gerne an
herrn professor exner reifen die phase 2
heißt ja dass man beginnen kann unter
bestimmten rahmenbedingungen maßnahmen
der strenge quarantäne sierung
kontrolliert zurücknehmen zu können das
muss aber genau dann abgestimmt werden
in der ersten phase ging es ja darum
dass hatte herr ministerpräsident
laschet gesagt sich vorbereiten zu
können bettenkapazitäten sicherstellen
zu können gleichzeitig auch die
bevölkerung einzuführen in die
entsprechenden maßnahmen das scheint
jetzt gelungen zu sein
in deutschland stellt man eine hohe
disziplin fest in der einhaltung dieser
maßnahmen und es ist jetzt die frage
inwieweit wir diese maßnahmen die wir
auf der einen seite in
lebensmittelbetrieben oder zum einkaufen
offensichtlich mit erfolg praktizieren
inwieweit das gegebenenfalls auch für
andere bereiche auch übertragen werden
kann
gleichzeitig bedeutet aber die phase 2
auch das in den bereichen wo wir eine
hohe vola hable bevölkerung haben
landrat pusch hat er das eben
angesprochen
das sind halt die krankenhäuser das sind
die alten und pflegeheime das ist die
ambulante versorgung auch insbesondere
von alten menschen wo wir ja auch
feststellen dass hier eine hohe qualität
letzten endes vorhanden ist wenn es zur
infektion kommt dass wir diese bereiche
in der phase 2 weiterhin maximal
schützen müssen
in den anderen bereichen wo wir jetzt
mit den klassischen verfahren die wir
hier eingeführt haben abstand zwar um
vor dem hintergrund in unerkannt kommt
es aus dem mund rachen raum zu einer
freisetzung von tröpfchen und es ist
eine tröpfcheninfektion dass wir mit
händehygiene mit husten etikette mit
dessen fiktion in bestimmten bereichen
einen maximalen effekt durchaus
erreichen wenn wir das aufrechterhalten
diese maßnahmen dass wir dann in
bestimmten bereichen die maßnahmen
beginnen können zu lockern immer unter
der voraussetzung dass die bevölkerung
diese maßnahmen ernst nimmt und dann
auch unter diesen bedingungen dann mit
macht das wäre dann auch weitere
bereiche des öffentlichen lebens wieder
so beginnen können durchzuführen das
eine eine strenge einer diese
vollständige quarantäne sierung wie wir
sie in anderen ländern zum teil haben wo
sie wie zum beispiel in frankreich ohne
eine genehmigung noch nicht mal
einkaufen können dass wir die hier bei
uns bei dem entsprechend kontrolliert
zurückführen können das heißt kontrolle
rücknahme von bestimmten
charakterisierung maßnahmen immer
kontrolliert unter strenger einhaltung
der entsprechenden hygienemaßnahmen ja
erst ganz kurz anschließend haben die
frage wenn sie ihn vielleicht kurz neue
grenzen mögen haben eine frage von kai
stoppel von n-tv der sich auch nach den
konkreten empfehlungen erkundigt hat da
haben sie ausgeführt und
hat uns eine frage erreicht nach der
situation in kindertagesstätten
einrichtungen und schulen welche
empfehlung können sie da konkret
aussprechen
diese fragen die sind derzeit auch in
der abstimmung man hat ja derzeit auf
einen notbetrieb auch ermöglicht wir
müssen sicher berücksichtigen dass die
erfahrung der verläufe zeigt dass
offensichtlich junge menschen deutlich
weniger gefährdet sind auch vor schweren
verläufen
die deutsche gesellschaft für wehr die
rad pädiatrische infektiologie hat einen
ein kataster aufgestellt wo alle
infektionen oder schwere verläufe bei
kindern aufgeführt sind und das ist
durchaus überschaubar geblieben
und insofern hat man in diesen fragen
dann zunächst mal gesagt für die
notbetrieb
wir empfehlen dass man risiko personen
wie zum beispiel kindergartenbetreuung
die über 60 sind zunächst mal zurück
nimmt in home office nimmt und dass auf
der anderen seite nur wenige kinder
zunächst mal zugelassen sind
die man dann wo dann abstands wahrung
einigermaßen umgesetzt werden kann
aber ich glaube wir können im augenblick
durchaus sagen dass nach allem was wir
wissen bei kindern schwere verläufe die
hat es gegeben bei chronisch kranken
kindern dass die doch sehr selten
aufgetreten sind
das ist ermutigend um dann zu
hinzugehen und dann die maßnahmen
gegebenenfalls kontrolliert auch
wiederum zurückzunehmen was die schulen
anbelangt da ist gerade im augenblick in
deutschland eine breite diskussion kann
man zum beispiel das abitur jetzt
kontrolliert durchführen
wir müssen diese diskussion abwarten wir
glauben aber dass wenn wir diese
abstands waren denn hygiene anhaltenden
verfahren gegebenenfalls auch unter
weitere maßnahmen wie händehygiene bevor
man in den raum hinein kommt dass man
das gegebenenfalls auch wird umsetzen
können wir sagen aber das sind maßnahmen
die wir aus hygienischer sicht empfehlen
die entscheidung ob man es so umsetzt
muss dann gesellschaftlich abgewogen
werden man darf ja nicht vergessen was
das für die jungen menschen bedeutet
wenn sie kein abitur durchführen können
das heißt phase 2 heißt ja nichts
anderes als unter einhaltung von
hygienemaßnahmen kontrolliert wo jeder
sich an diese maßnahmen hält das
zurückfahren zu können
ja er hat sich nach sechs eher wenige
was zu dem themenkomplex ich hätte da
eine kasse deutsche zeitung denn eine
nachfrage insofern das weiß ich nicht
jetzt genau ob das möglich ist auch den
ministerpräsidenten ein zu machen
die frage war ja eben schon mal konkret
nach den schulen ist eine extrem
wichtige debatte nicht nur in
nord-westfalen sondern auch im ganzen
bundesgebiet kann aus dem bevor die
jungs noch vorläufigen ergebnissen der
studie in heinsberg etwas abgeleitet
werden was der politik hilft die
entscheidung die in den nächsten zehn
tagen ansteht wie der eröffnung teil
eröffnung von schulen zu treffen kann
sie konkrete empfehlungen zu dieser
frage geben und herr laschet haben sie
das gefühl dass ihnen diese
rudisch und so viel hilft dessen heute
besser wissen als noch gestern
ob sie die entscheiden ob oder wie sie
diese entscheidung treffen
danach will ich ein besammeln die fragen
eine ministerpräsidenten vielleicht
genau und der studenten oder oder ist
mit ihrem eingangsstatement erledigt
oder ich kann ja der zu dir frage ja
nicht kann ja nur also ich sehe meine
aufgabe darin nur die daten und fakten
zu liefern ich glaube dass es wirklich
eine frage an den minister
bitte fragen ein minister beim anschluss
der hübschen dann dazu ich habe zwei
verständnisfragen eine verständnis frage
sie haben jetzt gesagt im kreis
heinsberg sind 15 prozent der bewohner
oder in gangelt bei ihrer untersuchung
sind 15 prozent nachweislich infiziert
gewesen
was heißt das denn für rückschlüsse auf
die dunkelziffer zu also wie hoch ist
die zahl die wir bisher kannten was
infizierte in gangelt angeht und lässt
sich das möglicherweise daneben auch auf
nordrhein westfalen oder aufs
bundesgebiet weil sich brauchen wir von
einer repräsentativen studie jetzt schon
hoch rechnen also wie viele infizierte
hätten wir dann dementsprechend
hochgerechnet in ganz deutschland und
noch eine verständnis frage an herrn
exner
sie haben gerade gesagt ist ja bekannt
dass kinder weniger schwere
krankheitsverläufe haben ich habe das
bisher jetzt immer so verstanden dass
man die schulen und die kindergärten
auch deshalb zu gemacht hat weil kinder
hatten dieses virus eben sie aber nicht
weiter tragen können also übertragen
können heißt es unter hygienischen
gesichtspunkten wenn wir die schulen
wieder aufmachen dann müssen die kinder
abstand von risikogruppen halten für die
erste frage würde ich einmal auch herrn
professor hartmann einbinden wollen ja
also die studie hat ja gezeigt dass 15
prozent der bevölkerung in gangelt in
diesem beispiel in dieser gemeinde
infiziert sind oder waren und das heißt
dass die auch immun sind es handelt sich
um eine erkrankung anders als bei
anderen virus infektionen die man wenn
man sie durchgemacht hat eine immunität
entwickelt und das virus dann letzten
endes auch den körper verlässt der
andere viruserkrankungen da ist es nicht
der fall
der eine chronische infektion und das
ist hier klar nicht so das heißt wer
krank überstanden hat hat eine immunität
und das virus ist auch nicht mehr
irgendwie schlafen schlummernd irgendwo
im körper zurückgeblieben
das ist ganz wichtig zu verstehen für
für dieses virus denn die 15 prozent das
ist eine ganz wichtige zahl weil wir
jetzt wissen an diesem beispiel und das
können wir aber nicht extrapolieren auf
ganz deutschland
weil eben hier eine sondersituation
vorliegt dass diese 15% sich beziehen
auf diese gemeinde und dort die
immunität vorherrscht wenn man jetzt und
das ist die wichtige frage die im raum
steht letzten endes die herdenimmunität
erreichen möchte oder nicht erreichen
kann weil die kosten für die bevölkerung
an leid und und wirtschaftlichen
einbußen einfach zu groß in an der
stelle wenn man diese immunität nicht
erreichen kann dann ist das hat das ganz
dramatische konsequenzen wenn wir aber
jetzt 15 prozent immunität in einem
solchen beispiel bereich haben dann
liegt diese 15 prozent liegen die nicht
so weit weg von den 60 prozent die wir
brauchen 60 70 für das erreichen einer
immunität wir können jetzt und wir sind
ganz vorsichtig seine bewertung von den
ersten ergebnissen dieser studie weil
natürlich vieles noch nicht bekannt ist
auch die zahl noch nicht ganz exakt sind
aber prinzipiell wäre man in der lage
auf basierend auf einer solchen studie
und weiteren studien die in ähnlicher
form durchgeführt werden derzeit auch
rückschlüsse zu ziehen was ist die
gesellschaft kosten würde dann nicht nur
geld sondern auch leid bis zu hin und
her zu kommen
das heißt wir sind jetzt bei 15 prozent
jede nominiert würde würde heißen 60
prozent erreichen zu müssen es geht es
vor allem darum zu entscheiden ist das
realistisch und kann man auf dem weg
dahin wie kann man den weg dahin so
gestalten dass die letalität die der
schweregrad der erkrankung möglichst
niedrig gehalten wird und da hat der ex
einer sehr ausführlich stellung genommen
zu jene maßnahmen wo wir überzeugt sind
dass wir den schweregrad der erkrankung
das heißt den verlauf den schweregrad
des verlaufes für das einzelne
individuum über hygienemaßnahmen
reduzieren können also nicht nur die
infektionsrate sondern auch den
schweregrad und das ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt weil wir davon ausgehen
dass die zahl der erreger bei
erstinfektion eines individuums einen
einfluss hat auf den schweregrad der
erkrankung so dass wir hoffen dass die
letalität die sich jetzt errechnet über
entsprechende maßnahmen die man
ergreifen kann über eine reduktion des
schweregrades bei dem einzelnen dann
nochmal deutlich reduziert werden kann
aber das sind alles bisher ganz
vorsichtige einschätzungen und wir
brauchen erst die daten den abschluss
dieser studie auch weitere studie
studien um hier wirklich aussagen machen
zu können
lothar schmalen an ericsson
jetzt noch nicht verstanden mit der
dunkel ist weil sie sagen 15 prozent
wieviel war dein bisher nachgewiesen in
gangelt bevor sie ihre studie angelegt
haben wieviel war durch die tests die
die gesundheitsämter machen die dann
noch ausgewiesen werden beim
robert-koch-institut oder
übersichtsseite wieviel waren da wie
viel prozent der bevölkerung war das ist
ja dann am ende in die dunkelziffer da
verstehe ich etwas falsch die
dunkelziffer wäre die differenz also
bisher ist die immunität die man
nachgewiesen hat gange ist jetzt ein
beispiel wo man im prinzip möglichst
breit und ihn und und intensiv gemessen
hat sodass dort zu erwarten ist dass die
dunkelziffer eigentlich weil eben das
sehr genau angeschaut worden ist die
dunkelziffer sehr niedrig ist weil
eigentlich da schon sehr wenn man schon
sehr weit mit der erfassung der zahlen
und die dunkelziffer ist in der größe
nennt nicht die dunkelziffer sondern die
die zahl die bisher im raume stand waren
fünf prozent
5 prozent jetzt 15 prozent das heißt es
kommt auch sehr gut ihn war wieder milde
und moderator von heute und einen großen
teil davon
die eben nicht primär getestet werden
wir die tests bisher vorbehält für die
wirklich erkranken wasserstrecke dienst
nur nur zur ergänzung ist es glaube ich
auch wichtig zu sehen was wir von
eingangs gesagt haben dass in solchen
hoch testgebieten wo sehr viel getestet
wurde ist glaube ich auch
bevölkerungsdichte einer der meist
getesteten orte dass dort die
dunkelziffer überschätzt wird
wir haben wir sie gemessen also wir
wissen dass dass die dunkelziffer ist
aber meistens würde man davon ausgehen
wir haben so viele fälle weil wir so
viel getestet haben in orten wo wir sehr
wenige infektionen haben wird sie häufig
sehr unterschätzt weil wir bei ihm viel
zu wenig getestet wurde also die
dunkelziffer ist eigentlich gar keines
gutes guter faktor um einen
infektionsgeschehen zu beschreiben weil
es abhängig ist vom von der anzahl der
der test die gefahren werden auch die
sterbe sterblichkeit ist abhängig von
der sterblichkeitsrate abhängig von wie
viele tests gemacht worden und daher
sollte der blickwinkel eigentlich viel
mehr auf die krankenhäuser gehen und die
maßnahmen
in der hygiene maßnahmen ich wollte das
noch mal ergänzen die bin dienstsitz ist
mitglied der kommission für
krankenhaushygiene beim
robert-koch-institut und unsere aufgabe
ist es ja durch hygienemaßnahmen
insbesondere im krankenhaus infektionen
die gravierend ablaufen können zu
vermeiden und die strategien der hygiene
sind ja letzten endes darauf
ausgerichtet es hatte braucht man eben
gesagt die zahl die konzentration von
krankheitserregern so zu minimieren dass
der körper auch der gesunde körper in
der lage ist damit fertig zu werden und
wünschenswert wäre es wenn er dann mit
dieser geringen zahl dennoch in der lage
ist eine immunität auszubilden das ist
ein sehr interessanter prozess der sich
jetzt hier abspielt und das jetzt komme
ich oft ihre frage wie sich das denn
jetzt in kindertagesstätten aus würden
wenn wir jetzt zu lassen das durchaus
auch kindertagesstätten wieder betrieben
werden
dann sagen wir wir halten
wir halten hygienemaßnahmen ein das
bezieht sich dann unter anderem halt
auch in kindertagesstätten auf wie die
reinigung die desinfektion spezieller
bereich um das risiko so gering wie
möglich zu halten wir haben bestimmte
kriterien auch für die für das die
mitarbeiterin die kindertagesstätten der
kindergarten pflegepersonal und so
weiter und so fort
wir halten aber dann in diesem in der
phase 2 wo wir beginnen die maßnahmen
zurückzufahren halten wir ein sehr hohes
maß an sicherheit für die wohngruppen
aufrecht dass die älteren die
gegebenenfalls chronische erkrankungen
haben
da werden wir weiterhin es für notwendig
halten dass die entsprechend geschützt
sind
aber die junge gesunde population in
einer bevölkerung dass die durchaus in
der lage ist
dieses natürliche immunität die wir
derzeit nicht erzeugen können durch eine
impfung da werden wir wahrscheinlich
noch bis zum ende des jahres mindestens
warten können dass die sich beginnt
natürlicherweise aufzubauen um dann
gleichzeitig sicherstellen zu können
dass wir diejenigen für das für die
diese infektion risikoreich ist maximal
zu schützen
das heißt auch in den in den
altenpflegeheimen und den krankenhäusern
da werden wir weiterhin eine restriktive
politik sicher aufrecht erhalten müssen
wenn ich schulen und kindergärten wieder
aufmache dann dürfen die kinder die
kindergärten und schulen besuchen durch
ihre worte richtig verstehe
wahrscheinlich bis ende des jahres ihre
großeltern nicht besuchen das können wir
nicht ausschließen also gerade in wir
sehen ja wenn sie sich die letalität
zahlen ansehen also die zahl derjenigen
die an dieser infektion sterben gucken
sich an in welchen altersgruppen es ist
die das durchschnittliche alter auch
nach angaben des robert koch institut
ist der verstorbenen liegt bei 80 jahren
von daher liegt es nahe diese besonders
zu schützen und deswegen kann können wir
nicht ausschließen dass in dieser phase
eine längere zeit der abstinenz zu den
besonders gefährdeten
bevölkerungsgruppen aufrechterhalten
werden muss ja wirklich eine ganze reihe
von fragen wie ich kündige an wir müssen
heute bisschen dosieren aber lothar
schmalen von der neuen westfälischen
es war eben von immunität die rede gibt
es erkenntnisse wie lange diese
immunität anhält und ob sie ausweiten
bis zum entwickeln eines impfstoffs oder
eines medikaments zu reichen
zweite frage relativ wenig gesagt worden
ist bisher über die erkenntnisse in
sachen infektionswege es war eben noch
einmal davon die rede dass es sich wohl
um eine tröpfcheninfektion handelt heißt
das dass die infektion über oberflächen
nur die berührung von infizierten
flächen keine rolle spielt und dann habe
ich nochmal zuletzt eine frage doch noch
mal zu der infektionsrate 15 prozent
heißt das jetzt dass diese erkenntnisse
aus dem kreis heinsberg überhaupt nicht
übertragbar sind auf auf allgemeine
zuständige oder gibt es doch vielleicht
so ein fenster was man schätzen kann wie
es dann wohl in dem im rest der republik
aussieht gut zu essen zu ersten frage
zur immunität wie lange besteht
immunität
nach dem was wir wissen kann das
zwischen sechs und 18 monaten seien also
durchaus limitiert das hängt sicherlich
auch von der höhe der antikörpertiter
insbesondere ab die sich bilden und das
ist inter individuell natürlich
unterschiedlich aber man kann sagen
sechs bis 18 monate also durchaus ein
limitierter zeitraum für diese
erkrankung
wenn man jetzt das ziel hätte jeden
immunität zu erreichen an der stelle
diese 60 70 prozent dann sollte das in
einem überschaubaren zeitraum
stattfinden weil es sonst sich
perpetuiert genau aus diesen gründen
limitierten immunität und da muss man
jetzt abwägen in welcher geschwindigkeit
und die geschwindigkeit kann man
wahrscheinlich in einer form
kontrollieren
diese erden immunität erreicht wird und
diese 60 70 prozent hießen dann das
virus verschwinden aus der population
komplett und die alten sind auch nicht
mehr gefährdet das heißt nicht nur die
60 70 prozent sind dann geschützt
sondern die 60 70 prozent schützen über
ihren eigenen schutz dann soweit die
population
dass das virus dann auch aus der
population komplett verschwindet und
damit sind ist der ältere teil der
bevölkerung natürlich auch wieder
geschätzt ja die übertragung und glaub
ich noch mal genau der haupt
übertragungsweg ist sicher der
übertragungsweg der direkten exposition
wenn ich jemanden an huste an über die
tröpfcheninfektion das ist stand das ist
gesichert die bedeutung der fläche wir
wissen dass die diese corona zwei viren
durchaus über einen längeren zeitraum
auch auf flächen überleben können
inwieweit es dann darüber dann wiederum
zu einer übertragung kommt das wird
weiter noch zu untersuchen sein aber es
bedeutet ja sie müssen von der fläche
die hände zb in eine schleimhaut sprich
mund augen hinein führen und das gehört
zu dem training dazu dass die
bevölkerung auch lernen muss lernt wie
geht er damit um und wir wissen aber auf
der anderen seite dass durch das
händewaschen gerade auch tenside also
eine seifen lösung die viren gut
abgelöst und durchaus auch in aktiviert
werden können
von daher hatten wir die möglichkeit
auch darüber techniken sicher umzusetzen
um dieses übertragungsrisiko auch
weiterhin zu minimieren
deswegen ist das händewaschen so banal
es klingt auch in dem fall eine ganz
wichtige funktion
aber was in der übertragung durchaus
halt auch ein problem darstellt ist das
offensichtlich in den frühen erkrankungs
phasen eine hohe last von viren im mund
rachen raum ist also
schon und von daher ist offensichtlich
die exposition aus diesem bereich so
wichtig dass wir den trainieren deswegen
kommt zum beispiel in bestimmten
bereichen die wir nicht kontrollieren
können wie dicht man aneinander steht
durchaus auch dass die frage tragen von
mundschutz die wir gerade in
krankenhäusern in der alten pflegeheim
für ganz wichtig halten deswegen
brauchen wir in diesen bereichen auch
gerade diese diese art des schutzes dass
wir das sehr ernst nehmen müssen und
deswegen sagen wir auch da brauchen wir
jetzt zunächst mal ganz viele
investitionen dass die mitarbeiter die
in diesen bereichen tätig sind diese
möglichkeit noch haben dann würde ich
ohne klose und rtl n tv das wort geben
und danach eine frage von zdf de vere
einschalten
die klose pushen sich eben gesagt 15%
infektions quote durch die eindämmung
dass man also gleich noch haus
quarantäne gegangen ist hat man eine
katastrophe vermieden würden sie das so
unterstreichen und ist das überhaupt so
auch auf deutschland zu projizieren
dass wir relativ schnell diese auf haus
quarantäne gegangen sind um schlimmeres
zu vermeiden ist das vielleicht auch ein
grund dass es bisher relativ glimpflich
im international vergleicht abgegangen
ist nun die im kreis heinsberg war ja
eine ganz besondere situation dass das
virus reingekommen in der zeit wo wir es
erst angefangen haben zu verstehen und
daher waren die maßnahmen
anfang richtig um das einzudämmen damit
wir alle die hygienemaßnahmen wieder ins
uns ins gedächtnis rufen und auch lernen
wie wir damit umgehen und ich denke auch
in der bundesrepublik waren die
maßnahmen richtig und auch wichtig da
eine erstmal eine eindämmung zu erlangen
jetzt sind wir an einem punkt angekommen
wo wir damit ja damit lernen müssen um
zu gehen weil saß 2 wird in unserer
bevölkerung oder wird wahrscheinlich in
der bevölkerung bleiben zum zweiten
punkt für die über das war auch hier
punkt gerade wie das übertragbar ist auf
diese stichprobe auf die
gesamtbevölkerung ich glaube es gibt
zwei wichtige kenngrößen die wir da
einmal haben damit die gesamtmortalität
die sich aus der gemeinde gangelt
natürlich plusminus prozent zahlen wie
man statistisch im moment recht rechnet
so sowie die letalität also wie viele
von den personifizierten verstärken
in der frage mit der immunität also wie
hoch die dunkelziffer durchseuchung ist
dass es sehr schwer zu sagen aber ich
sage es mal so rum in einem gebiet wo
wir so viele infektionen gesehen haben
ihren gangelt und so viele tests
durchgeführt haben kann man
rückschließen dass dort wahrscheinlich
die dunkelziffer die gleiche ist und
auch die immunität die gleiche weise
eine repräsentative stichprobe ist aber
es hängt natürlich davon ab
ich weiß ich bin auch usedom bisher noch
kein ich weiß es wirklich keinen fall
bisher gewesen ist kann es auch sein
dass es da auch keine immunität bisher
gibt also dass das hängt eben sehr davon
ab wie die verteilung in deutschland ist
ich weiß aber kennen aber auch die daten
von e zentrum jetzt haben wir eine frage
die per video zugeschaltet wird hinter
ihrer bosse hatten und das ist peter
böhme vom zdf das ensi professor strich
gefahr geraten oder anderen zuhörer
dunkelziffer an paketen die gleiche
richtung man kann den 15 prozent
sicherlich nicht auf dem platz der
republik übertragen aber vielleicht halt
die vitalität wenn sie im gang wird auf
einen wert
in einer repräsentativen stichprobe von
0,37 kommen und johns hopkins für die
ganze republik von 198 also fünfmal
soviel dann müsste man doch eigentlich
auch die der hut sein in deutschland
erkranken 110 120 tausend mal könne und
daneben auch die entsprechende dunkelt
sich bei der infektionszahlen zu kommen
oder rechnet er übernimmt die aufgabe
hat man sie gut also es geht um die die
letalität der wurde der zahlenwert und
wir haben den zahlenwert ihren kontext
gesetzt der vorläufigen ergebnisse
dieser studie allzu viel wird sich da
aber erwartungsgemäß jetzt an dem wert
nicht verändern
der wert ist deswegen fünfmal niedriger
herr strich hatte das auch schon
ausgeführt ist deswegen fünfmal
niedriger im vergleich jetzt mit anderen
letalität daten weil wir uns auf die
gesamtzahl der infizierten jetzt
beziehen können und diese gesamtzahl der
infizierten bislang in diese
berechnungen der vitalität nicht
einbezogen werden konnten und weltweit
eigentlich genau diese daten gefordert
werden wo wir jetzt die ersten daten in
diese richtung liefern können und das
ist auch die relevanz dieses wertes
jetzt dieses vorläufigen wert ist aus
dieser studie speziell in gang hält zu
sagen wir haben 0,37 prozent an
letalität bezogen auf alle infizierten
und wenn man jetzt kann man im prinzip
extrapolieren was würde das bedeuten
bezogen auf die gesamtbevölkerung wie
ganz richtig gefragt wird sind die ist
die zahl der gesamte pc
dann entsprechend fünfmal so hoch ich
glaube diese bewertung kann man noch
nicht abschließend jetzt hier erklären
aber die daten die wir haben und weitere
daten die erhoben werden werden dazu
führen dass man genauso eine abschätzung
machen kann und dann entsprechende
vorausberechnungen der eines möglichen
gesamtverlauf machen kann
wir haben immer wieder uns auch für jene
maßnahmen auch bezogen und die hoffnung
ist dass man über hygienemaßnahmen
diesen wert der ja entstanden ist in
einem super spreading event sehr schnell
weiter reduziert werden kann
das heißt die hoffnung ist und das ist
die aufgabe an die wissenschaft aber
auch die politik zu erreichen dass jetzt
im weiteren verlauf dieser letalität
wird minimiert wird über maßnahmen wie
möglichst kluge maßnahmen die dazu
führen dass die gesamt negativ
auswirkungen diese infektion bis zum
erreichen einer gesamt immunität tolle
rat in irgendeiner form tolerabel wird
es gibt im endeffekt nur zwei
möglichkeiten fertig zu werden das eine
ist eine vakzine an der hand zu haben da
sind wir uns alle einig wird zu lange
dauern mindestens ein jahr ein jahr lang
kann man irgendwie einen kompletten
shutdown wirtschaftlich schwer
verkraften also muss man gucken dass die
immunität von anderer seite kommt oder
man verkraften diesen globalen
wirtschaftlichen shutdown mit allen
konsequenzen das ist eine unglaublich
wichtige entscheidung wir haben nur
einen kleinen schritt jetzt mit dieser
mit dieser mit diesen daten in die die
in die richtung führen wird dass man
eine einschätzung haben kann wie man
sich jetzt am besten in die nächsten
monate hinein verhalten ja jetzt wir
müssen auswählen deswegen mache ich das
auch mit blick auf die frage der
ministerpräsident noch gerichtet sind
ich würde drei fragen wir ausgewählte
stellen christian wolff vom wdr fragte
professor steg in die fed haben sie
inwieweit haben sie in ihrer studie
berücksichtigt dass die antikörper test
momentan noch falsch positive ergebnisse
liefern ihr vorgänger in bonn professor
thorsten
weil sie darauf hin so schreibt er dass
diese tests auch dann positiv aus
schlagen können wenn jemand eine
infektion mit normalen erkältung skoda
viren hinter sich gehabt habe
beeinträchtigt die ich nicht die
aussagekraft ihre ergebnisse ja damit
haben wir uns gemeinsam sehr viel
beschäftigt auch mit positiven
ergebnisse oder falsch negative
ergebnisse
wir gehen von den daten aus die wir im
moment haben ich hatte vorhin auch
gesagt dass wir einer mit einer anderen
einschätzung in einem anderen test auf
einen wert von über 20% immunität haben
das haben wir rausgenommen erstmal
beiseite konservativ im moment rechnen
so dass wir im moment von einer
spezifität die hat das wichtige dabei
ist in dieser fragestellung bei 15
prozent liegen jörg walker von der bild
zeitung fragt sie professor steht im ruf
steht wie werden sie ist dass das
bundesligaspiel borussia mönchengladbach
gegen borussia dortmund am 7 märz vor
publikum stattgefunden habe und haben
sie erkenntnisse darüber ob und
inwiefern der spiel zum multiplikator
des virus geworden sein könnte die
entscheidung kann ich nicht beurteilen
aber wir haben auch keine erkenntnisse
und haben wir auch übrigens nicht
abgefragt zum spiel von borussia
dortmund also da kann ich nichts zu
sagen
sodann eine frage die wir noch zu
schalten und zwar von unique riske von
bloomberg woran sie was zeigen diese
ergebnisse über wie anstecken
dieses virus im kreis dann können sie
sehen eine hohe ansteckungsrate oder
eine andere als in lugano eine
niedrigere und was können wir daraus
lernen
vielen dank wir über die also die das
ansteckungseffekt von dem wir im moment
ausgehen der karnevalssitzung das
analysieren wird derzeit noch und dazu
können wir noch nichts sagen
und haben auch bisher noch keine 40
werte also reproduktions ziffer
bestimmen können so mit blick auf die
leichten vorstudien der landtagssitzung
würde ich jetzt infrage
ministerpräsident laschet kommt erstmal
herzlichen dank an sie
ich würde sagen wir knüpfen trägt dann
die frage von den bernecker an dass der
präsident sich beginnen dann mit der
frage von herrn wernicke in unserem
expertenbeirat hat udo di fabio über das
was wir alles tun im moment gesagt das
sind risikoentscheidungen unter
unsicherheits bedingungen also die
politik reagiert auf werte die man
greift wir berichten täglich
infektionszahlen die eigentlich relativ
wenig aussagen denn wenn man mehr testet
gehen die infektionszahlen potenziell
hoch wir sehen todeszahlen die aber auch
zu nichts in einer relation gesetzt
werden
und deshalb braucht man bei diesen
unsicherheits bedingungen weitere
facetten und untersuchungen um zu
verantwortlichen entscheidungen zu
kommen und die entscheidung des lockdown
den wir gerade haben hat auch schäden
verursacht ist es nicht die frage ob
wenn wir ins leben ins öffentliche leben
zurückkehren ob dann schäden entstehen
sondern mit dem was wir heute machen
entstehen stellen schäden psychologische
gesundheitliche wirtschaftliche für
menschen die depressiv sind depressive
auswirkung kindeswohl gewalt all die
schäden entstehen im moment tag für tag
und wenn man dann eine andere
entscheidung treffen will braucht man
dafür eine grundlage und deshalb erwäge
ist diese studie ein weiterer baustein
der uns hilft zu einer verantwortlichen
entscheidung zu kommen und wie die dann
aussehen wird wenn wir am mittwoch mit
der bundeskanzlerin und den 16
ministerpräsidenten
sprechen mir ist wichtig dass
insbesondere alle fragen die schule und
kita betreffen möglichst einvernehmlich
getroffen werden anerkennen dass in den
ländern die situation anders ist
hessen hat schon abitur geschrieben
insofern stellt sich in hessen die
abitur frage nicht für
nordrhein-westfalen stellt sie sich das
liegt an unterschiedlichen ferienzeiten
aber dass die prinzipielle frage wie
kehren wir zurück ins öffentliche leben
oder wie das hier ziemlich formuliert
ist beginnt die phase 2 mit der
rücknahme der quantifizierung bei
gleichzeitiger sicherung hygienische
rahmenbedingungen diese frage werden wir
nächste woche beantworten müssen und
dafür ist die studie ein wichtiger
anlass aber noch kein die
wissenschaftler sagen uns nicht mehr aus
so oder so sondern sie geben uns einen
weiteren baustein an die hand henrik
hübschen herr ministerpräsident sie
haben jetzt auch noch mal erkennen
lassen dass die infektionszahlen wie wir
sie im moment beobachten und die zahlen
des robert-koch-instituts regionshaus
kanns ja wenig aussagekräftig sind
trotzdem geben sie erlauben aber auch
die kanzlerin immer auf die verdoppelung
rate dieser zahlen ab die jetzt sind
macht das fahren bei 12 liegt ist es
dann eigentlich das falsche kriterium
was man betrachtet ja wir können ja weil
es eine völlig neue krankheit ist und
wir unter schönes wort immer unter
unsicherheits bedingungen arbeiten nur
mit dem arbeiten was uns vorliegt und
wir mussten reagieren auf eine situation
umzudenken kommt ein tat iks wo unser
gesundheitssystem überfordert ist das
ist das was wir bisher gemacht haben
herr professor streik hat gesagt die
politik hat hier bisher richtig
gehandelt
man wusste wenig und hat deshalb die
sicherste methode gewählt um die
infektionszahlen die verbreitung zu
verringern
aber dass man sich so sehr nur an den
infektionszahlen orientiert das macht
die politik diesmal übrigens auch die
medien
jede nachrichtensendung beginnt damit
wie viel wie die infektionszahlen
hochgegangen und dann illustriert man
das mit einer kurve eigentlich eine fast
irrelevante frage für das was wir
eigentlich zu entscheiden haben aber
dass wir alle lernen tag für tag und
dass wir heute noch einmal mehr gelernt
haben durch die studie ist glaube ich
etwas was uns die nächsten wochen sehr
häufig passieren wird entscheidend ist
dass man fundiert aus dieser krise
wieder heraus kommt und mich überzeugt
das argument dass das dass die deutschen
in den letzten wenigen wochen gelernt
haben worauf es ankommt und die kontakt
verbote und die distanz und sind abstand
und die hygieneregeln einhalte
und wenn das so ist ermutigt das über
den nächsten schritt nachzudenken
lucas eberle vom spiegel hat eine drei
fragen die ich zusammen fast ein anderer
stelle eine ministerpräsidentin welchen
lebens und arbeitsbereichen ist für sie
nach dem 19 april eine lockerung der
maßnahmen denkbar
zu welchen erkenntnissen sind sie bei
den treffen mit dem expertenrat gelangt
da und sie ausgeführt und letzte frage
in dem kontext können sie sich
vorstellen dass die profi ligen im
deutschen fußball den spielbetrieb
wieder aufnehmen selbstverständlich ohne
zuschauer also der expertenrat seine
arbeit noch nicht abgeschlossen
diese ergebnisse werden wir rechtzeitig
vor der konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundeskanzlerin haben welche bereiche
das sind wird man dann ebenfalls achten
müssen
habt ihr das eine beispiel genannt der
bäckerei die derzeit geöffnet ist als
lebensmittel ist oder des supermarktes
der geöffnet ist als lebensmittel ist
der held heute hygienevorschriften 1
man kann sich natürlich gleichermaßen
vorstellen dass ein autohaus auch
hygiene bedingungen einhält
also man kann an der oder ein kleiner
ladenburg kaum menschen eingehen und wo
immer mal eine oder zwei sich aufhalten
die können hygiene bedingungen einhalten
und der übergang zum kriterium
hygienebedingungen 1
abstandsregeln einhalten statt des
totalen schließen
das ist etwas über das wir im moment
nachdenken aber entscheidungen fallen
ist am nächsten mittwoch und zur
bundesliga ist ja alles gesagt worden
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass wir
in dieser saison noch mal volle stadien
haben werden
das geisterspiele denkbar sind ist etwas
was die liga im moment mit den ländern
erörtert
dann habe ich mir die letzte frage von
matthias im radio von thomson reuters
ministerpräsident sollen mögliche erste
schritte zu einer öffnung des
öffentlichen lebens in nordrhein
westfalen mit belgien und den
niederlanden koordiniert werden sollen
einheitliche regeln gelten
und was passiert wenn belgien und die
niederlande einen anderen weg wählen
würden ja das ist eine besonders
schwierige fall gerade für unsere
nachbarn westfalen weil wir versuchen
natürlich erstmal einen konsens der 16
deutschen länder zu erzielen wenn wir
hier zu einer öffnung kommen könnte das
eine andere situation ein sein als sie
derzeit in belgien den niederlanden ist
und das müssen wir in unserer
grenzüberschreitenden anhalt ad hoc
arbeitsgruppe betrachten wir haben heute
schon die situation dass der
österreichische bundeskanzler für
österreich neueröffnungen vorgeschlagen
hat die haben dann wiederum auswirkungen
auf bayern
also das ist auch etwas was mit am
mittwoch eröffnet der hübschen dass man
inzwischen auch eine kleine anfrage der
spd dazu gibt das projekt heinsberg
protokoll wird ja social media von story
maschinen begleitet andererseits wird
das projekt vom land finanziert war dass
damit drin also diese pr arbeit
historische maschinen macht oder wie ist
das zu stande
es ist eine typische oppositions anfrage
das land fördert eine wissenschaftliche
studie
und wer wie wien berät bei dieser
bei der großen öffentlichkeitsarbeit die
da im moment ja wohl weltweit da ist
entzieht sich der kenntnis des landes
jedenfalls hat das land keine pr bezahlt
um das gleich klipp und klar auszuräumen
ich habe die anfrage von frau philipp
gesehen wäre der ungewöhnlicherweise
noch am heutigen tag sie beantworten
damit wirklich solche verstörenden
anfragen direkt aufgeklärt sind aus
sicht des landes in dieser stimmung
gehen wir zu den landtag herzlichen dank
wir kommen auf bald